dans les nouveaux textes 1 c'est-à-dire
liés à l'épidémie du comité 19 il est
prévu un versement de la rémunération à
hauteur de 70 % du salaire brut
84 % du salaire net qui vont être versés
directement par l'employeur au salarié
100 % de la rémunération quand pour les
personnes qui sont au smic
7 cette rémunération là qui va verser
une indemnité
il est versé puisqu'elle n'a pas la
nature du salaire de l'employeur au
salarié va être remboursée par l'état
aux employeurs en totalité pour les
personnes qui touchent jusqu'à 4,5
points le smic et au-delà ce sera
l'employeur de faire le maintien de
salaire pour arriver aux 84 % du net
dans le calcul un parent par mois du
chômage partiel ne sont pas pris en
compte dans la rémunération tout ce qui
est intéressant et participations 13e
mois ou primes de fin d'année où le
reste est pris en compte
quand on est en chômage partiel donc en
activité partielle en chômage partiel ou
technique
on peut être en chômage partiel
totalement à temps plein c'est à dire
que l'employeur vous dit vous restez
chez vous vous ne travaillez pas on peut
être aussi en chômage partiel partiel
c'est à dire que on peut par exemple
rester chez soi et ne pas travailler
être ton camp chômage partiel lundi
mardi mercredi et de voir venir
travailler ou travaillante et travaille
d'ailleurs jeudi vendredi
tu as fait la première chose à savoir
quand vous êtes en chômage partiel sur
les heures qui sont visés par ce chômage
partiel ne pouvait pas travailler votre
employeur ne peut pas légalement vous
demander de travailler
et s'il le faisait il ya des amendes
pénales c'est l'article 141 1-6 du code
pénal qui prévoit jusqu'à deux ans
d'emprisonnement et 30 mille euros
damende pour un employeur il se
retrouverait dans cette situation-là de
te forcer ou de demander à ses salariés
de travailler alors qu'ils sont en
chômage partiel
autre précision pour répondre au mieux à
ces à ces questions là on se met pas
soualais en chômage partiel est une
démarche que fait l'employeur auprès des
services de la préfecture et la direccte
en ligne éventuellement pour un ou
plusieurs pour un groupe en principe de
salariés un salarié seul n'est pas visé
c'est en service un groupe de salariés
doit déposer une demande alors l'aller
les les procédures et les et les délais
sont forcément accéléré et c'est lui qui
décide sur la base de critères objectifs
qu'elle est le salarié ou en principe le
groupe de salariés ils vont être visés
par ce chômage partiel
il est précisé que une salariée ne
peuvent pas refuser ce placement en
chômage partiel
pour répondre précisément à cette
question sur l'activité partielle je le
redis un actif quand je dis activité
partielle c'est chômage partiel ou en
chômage technique 1 c'est la même chose
là dessus c'est un dispositif qui existe
depuis un certain nombre d'années un qui
est mis en place donc on connaît bien il
y à des adaptations qui ont été décidées
par les gouvernements à travers
d'ordonnancé d'écrire qui ont été donc
publié ce matin et sur ce sujet là
précisément il était prévu avant même la
publication de ces ordonnances sur cette
situation particulière de l'épidémie du
de kobe 2009 il n'y a pas de
modification particulière là dessus que
quand on est en arrêt de travail séparé
la va prévaloir sur le chômage partiel
est à dire qu on est en arrêt de travail
jusqu'à la fin prévue par le parlement
de saint parres l'arrêt travail et
ensuite le chômage partiel le dispositif
de chômage partiel va prendre le relais
donc on peut imaginer c'est pas dit
comme ça dans les textes pas prévue
avant le un arrêt de travail pour garde
d'enfants va suivre absolument
le même régime